[Music]
this is a black
you're perfect you're just like a perch
he's wondering who's got the weirder
hairstyle he's like is he good he's
checking out your hair up
I'm gonna let you feed him that walnut
and the reason for that is that check
out the massive whoa okay and that's a
powerful jaw right yes I'm just gonna
say check out that massive beak on this
bird this this it's kind of parrot its
it's a black palm cockatoo native to
Australia parts of Southeast Asia that
giant bill is designed to do what it's
doing right now which is which is crush
nuts and they can take palm nuts which
are super super hard and exert 1,500
pounds of pressure with that bead and
just crush right through that I think
you're spelling sounds sorry didn't mean
it didn't mean it it's cool you just
keep doing it you look how delicate he
is with the time yeah you know and
that's getting the knot out of there and
they use that tongue it's almost like
got like a finger and this this species
bill is so big that beak is so big but
they actually can't even shut their
mouths completely so that tongue kind of
almost works in the same way that you
know like if your thumb would work and
if you can see that that's exactly what
he's doing he's reaching in and he's
actually able to pull that walnut right
out of that she'll just with his tongue
it's pretty fascinating incredible this
is a very strange experience yeah
but I'm very calm and he seems calm he
is he isn't you know he likes you
because his crest is totally up yeah
a win in height but look at that how
anything huh yeah yeah
all right I think we have what do you
think Jeff should we just do what do you
think one more we got one more quick one
right here in the performance area yeah
and this one is gonna require this okay
this animal is it's a balloon it's this
animal is a kind of reptile and hello it
is actually a species I want to step
over here color if you just want to stay
behind me yeah I'll stay behind you this
is a Nile crocodile okay do you want to
let that thing go she'll be okay once we
get her Oh she'll be fine it's us I'm
worried about so you can see this is
even as a juvenile this is only about a
five foot animal this is a species that
can get to be that this animal can get
to be 15 to even 20 feet long and you
know their crocodiles most people know
that crocodiles are you know tremendous
predators when they get to their full
growth they're actually able to take
down you know animals this big of zebras
so look at that hate stairs hang out
there it's just like you son of a [ __ ]
let's see if we can get her to show
those two known you $20 four years ago
I don't think she's gonna work work for
us you know she's not gonna open up her
mouth too big there well she looks
really mad so the hope poking it with a
stick with a stick but yeah you know
check her out I mean she is beautifully
adapted to live in the environments
these guys are found in Africa it's the
largest reptile in Africa it's only
smaller than the saltwater crocodiles
have it's just the kind of animal they
could you know eat us it absolutely
could unfortunately in some instances
these animals do prey on people in
Africa although they do prefer natural
prey but yeah you know sometimes you
know when predators and people you know
cross paths yeah you know there is a
conflict but yeah one of these you're
bringing it here to the television show
if you look at the fourth tooth yeah get
in there with your finger and show me
yeah no I'm not gonna do that
that fourth ten can tell I need to see
specifically what you picked up from the
bottom there that's one one really good
way to tell alligators for crocodiles
alligators are also kind of like a dark
blackish color they have a big wide fat
head and they're actually a lot more
chill than crocodiles are and she for a
crocodile is actually doing really well
she's she's almost just kind of going
into little trance there but but
crocodiles
they have attitude if you don't really
want a little bit of a train of them but
I'd hate to see this thing when it's in
a trance
it is so stoned right now look at it
he's just thinking about the late
sixties crazy stuff went down on the
Nile alright we're gonna get some
smelling salts and coffee for this guy